I'm Dave joined by tomorrow Sain and
this is our video review for Socorro
shadows die twice the souls born world
is a world that means a hell of a lot to
a hell of a lot of people it's really
meaningful to me I know it's really
meaningful to you so SEC you know being
an extension of that how did it feel to
finally play this game yeah so like you
said I'm incredibly obsessed with From
Software's games in their worlds you
know completely the souls games multiple
times so for those two not you
blood-borne is a game that I've platinum
I fall asleep almost weekly to like law
videos shower tivity and Dave control
life so they are very very close to him
to me and my heart and so Sakura was
just kind of exciting experience but
also made me quite nervous because this
is one of the first games that has been
made up from software since Miyazaki
became president and he's made it very
clear that he wants to do something
different and step away from the
traditional soldiers thing that they're
known for so there's also quite a
nervous experience for me because I was
like this is a develop I really love and
if I don't like this that's another
three to four years before I'll get
something out of them so it was a kind
of was also an exciting opportunity to
see what they can do beyond that songs
format and I'm pleased to say that it
was quite spectacular it was banging I'm
having such an exciting time the the
differences that it's brought to the
Dark Souls kind of formula while it be
while it's recognizable obviously
longtime fans like us I think that it's
also bringing enough new stuff that it's
it's going to be exciting for new
players yeah get into one of the most
defining things for all of these games
is the combat especially how different
the Dark Souls the blood board is it's
then extremely different from the jump
to second row so tell us you know in
detail how the combat has kind of
changed yeah so in my review which is
available now on GameSpot calm my
written review I kind of open it by
talking about how it's a familiar
experience and I think
is very much the case like the building
blocks of the combat are very very
familiar and to someone who's like not
super played a lot of Sakura if you just
show them a video they'll say it looks
the same but what it kind of wants from
you is to play on its terms more the
previous games kind of gave you this
freedom to kind of behave in the way you
want the souls games for example meant
you could either be like a magician type
character or you could you know be a
warrior style or you know it's very that
kind of stuff and blood-borne had the
kind of like a little more of a push way
wanted you to be aggressive but it gave
you loads of weapons and styles and you
can still have like a hit and run style
kind of approach to it whereas sakura
has a defined way to play it it's built
around the imagery of swords clashing
and that you have to keep in mind that's
what it wants from you it wants to put
you in a situation where you are taking
your fight to the player to the other
enemy sorry and kind of clashing swords
and then using the opportunity to
counter their moves and then strike with
a deathblow and I think because of that
the challenge in the game for people
like me and you and the many many other
souls fans out there is kind of
unlearning the mentality that we've
built up here that muscle memory that
you have yeah because it is recognizable
when you pick up the game as it being
you know part of this kind of souls
borne world instantly I was moved to
kind of hold guard or I was dodging or
jumping away far too much and that's
just not the way that Sakura is built
yeah I think it's important to say that
like it's not impossible with that
mentality because they're normal enemies
they're a little more lenient you can
get away with that like D like the hit
and run style you can do that there but
the thing is if you're doing that too
much you're not learning what the game
wants from you you're not training
yourself to kind of like the it's all
built around a star called posture and
that is basically the ability to not be
staggered by an attack and the way you
wear that down in an enemy is you
counter their attack as their hitting
and it's a very specific timing and that
kind of breaks posture eventually and
leads to a deathblow which is an instant
strike quick fast blur flourish to build
up the kind of like the skills to do
that
you need to practice it
and if you don't do that and you still
stick to the Dark Souls blood-borne Stan
mentality when you reach a mini boss or
a boss they are gonna wipe the floor
with you for hours and hours and hours
on end and I know that because it
happened to me like I I had like a mixed
approach when I when I came into the
game like there were some enemies where
I do that with but I clearly wasn't
throwing myself into combat and then I
got to a boss that literally took me six
hours and it was because I wasn't
willing to commit to the way it wants me
to play and the vision that from stuff I
had for the combat once I kind of really
took I took one death really really hard
and it just like really like it made me
flip a switch and I was like I'm sick of
this kind of like really long drawn-out
battle where I'm like pulling away and
like very carefully me waiting for those
very rare happening and I just went in
like I just got up and ran straight at
the guy and it was just Perry Perry
Perry Perry Perry Perry Perry and within
six minutes I was done
that's what I've been really loving
about Sakura so far really plays to the
players confidence and it has tools to
reward that confidence and the more
confident you get with your combat the
more rewarding it becomes and the more
you can feel yourself getting better as
your own confidence grows which is a
kind of formula that a lot of games
struggle with but Sakura some fights you
do really do feel like Master bad a
shinobi when you're pairing every single
fluorine you're demolishing fights
without a hit being taken yeah I think a
lot of people speak to how challenging
this game is and it is difficult like
nailing the timing is difficult not
being careful and getting yourself into
skirmishes big ones is can make it
challenging I think the greatest
challenge in this game comes from the
it's like a mental challenge do you have
the fortitude to stand back up pick
yourself back up and go back into a
fight because that's what these games
are and more so with Sakura than any
other game it's about going into a fight
a tricky one with the objective of
learning something like finding a new
move or figured getting one step closer
to learning that timing and you have to
accept that in the process of doing that
you will die but when you come back
you'd be that just slightly a little
more equipped to deal with it and over
time you'll reach the point where you've
you've downloaded this boss you figure
them out you know exactly how to
approach it or this enemy and when you
do it there's nothing like the
satisfaction of it because you've had
that six hours or wherever it may be of
getting stomped and so when you defeat
it it is there's few feelings that I can
kind of like compare to it it's just
completely overwhelming and each time
I've done it it's been adrenaline and
like heart pounding I need to put the
controller down I need to step away and
as for my money there's no other game
out there that offers a similar
experience of course going face-to-face
and clashing swords with the enemy is
just one method of getting through the
world stealth is just a huge part of
Sakura and that's something we haven't
seen yet from software game tell me what
your huge stealth yeah as you know and
like I tweeted this as well like if this
game feels like it was directly
okay let me because like as well as the
souls games my other major passion a
stealth games whether that's primarily
the Metal Gear franchise but Splinter
Cell Dishonored any other stealth game
I'm out there and so the fact that this
game has stealth is so so like
satisfying for me and so so enjoyable
and I think the stealth plays are really
really important part so like the game
has its origins in being a kind of
spiritual successor to taint you and you
can see that there's as well as having
these kind of one-on-one battles you
have the opportunity to kind of like
skulk around and it has like very basic
stealth mechanics that largely are a
revolve around positioning yourself
behind enemies or above enemies using
your grappling hook to move around kind
of like sneaking you get into a crouched
position and very slowly walking to
position yourself so you can deliver
deathblows that has kind of like
two-fold impact on the game itself one
you're thinning out the crowd because in
most places there's a difficult enemy
that you will inevitably go on to take
on and if there's other people about
other enemies about you're gonna have a
bad time yeah so effectively your
evening the odds against this one main
enemy by thinning out the crowd and
fighting hordes is it can be a nightmare
in second they don't stand around there
all comfy at the same time and it's
tricky to like land counters when the
multiple enemies are attacking it's
doable but it's very high failure rate
as well as thinning out the crowds you
get an experience that you can use to
you know unlock new abilities and flesh
out your character or Cammy or you get
money to buy stuff top of that you're
kind of filling up the bar that allows
you to or the kind of like energy that
allows you to revive when you die yeah
so that's one of the things that makes
it slightly easier but there are
consequences to reviving when you're
dying reviving and dying and kind of
like the loop of it which we won't get
into because it's yes a kind of spoiler
in story of these games is something
that's very precious to a lot of people
so we're getting yeah just focus to the
mechanics in the world yes so many
people just gonna want experience that
forms beyond the mechanical stuff the
the stealth is really really good for
building that mental fortitude almost
giving you like a confidence boost yeah
because you're taking out a lot of
enemies so you feel good it's so like an
ego stroke almost so you feel that a
little more empowered to go towards an
enemy and
towards a boss so it is this kind of
like this balance this urban flow
between really tricky stuff and the
stuff that's a little more your own pace
that you can dictate how a fight you go
into a fight of course that fight that
you never to go into it's still
difficult but you've made it a little
bit easier stuff and you feel a bit
better about yourself and also you get
to look at the world and that wall is
very very impressive yeah it's I think
it's very much been designed with the
tenants of Sakura and mind there's the
verticality the thoughts on exploration
I was saying to you before playing
blood-borne and Dark Souls there was
always really a defined path or a fine
couple of paths but now the sensation of
looking behind you looking in like very
small nooks and crannies I know that was
that was a thing in Dark Souls but never
was there so much attention paid to
looking off the beaten track looking up
looking around you and seeing the
potential of other avenues of attack and
exploration yeah so like I said again in
my review which is up on the site from
software one of the main things that
they're praised for is their world
construction right it's going into this
world the small area playing through it
and going into another one and being
like oh this actually fits into the the
previous one and the areas that I've
come through and then you very slowly
build a larger picture of the entirety
of Lordran drangleic you know you're on
and whatever it may be but usually can
take it can take a little while to see
that bigger picture in Sakura though
like you arrive to an area and you can
almost immediately see how the area
falls in on itself you can see the the
thoughtfulness that has gone into the
construction almost immediately like
you're standing on top of a building
you'll see a path like that is kind of
like threading itself in between the the
enemies but off to the side you'll see
like a tangle of tree branches that it's
just going around it and you can see
just above the tangle of free branches
there's a roof and you know if I jump
onto that tree branch I'll bet you at
the end I'll be able to grapple hook
onto the roof and it'll put me behind
one of the enemies and I can backstab
and like that satisfaction of going
around enemies and kind of like
in-between them and and following the
like twisting turning paths and the
following paths are kind of like thin
out the crowd and really explore the the
the intricacies of each level is so so
like
and rewarding from a stealth perspective
because it means like your your this
ghost and you can be everywhere it
almost feels like you're tricking the
game yeah the game is designed to make
you want to do that but then when you do
all this exploration you feel like
you're you're the smart one you fooled
yeah and that's on a micro level like
it's that's not to say the bigger stuff
isn't there like on a wider via taking a
wider view the areas do link back into
each other I had a moment where I was
like 20 or 20 hours into the game and at
one point I went through an area and it
brought me back to us to the starting
area and I realized that I could have
come to this area at the very start of
the game there's nothing to prevent me
to go there and that was like a
mind-blowing moment again the kind that
you have like we had when we were in
playing Dark Souls for the first time
and you get that kind of like that
strength of world design is really
really apparent here and it's it's such
an interesting way to kind of make you
place greater scrutiny on the world
around you and inevitably when you do
that you get to see how beautiful it is
as well like it's also visually quite
arresting oil yeah it's stunning yeah
and it's a little more grounded in
reality than previous stuff but that
doesn't mean they don't have fun with it
and they don't make it look interesting
there's like the natural beauty is there
but there's also some fantastical stuff
as well that shows up a little later
into the game and that kind of like when
you see that stuff it almost lands
harder because so you're so used to
seeing the normal things yeah that when
something like a demon appears you're
like what was that that was so weird and
like you kind of it gets your heart
racing yeah so the world is absolutely
phenomenal I think it's it's a game
that's had a lot of questions about it
we reached out in Twitter to ask for
some of your questions and so we've got
a few here the first one from joseph
haydn which do you think players will
find more difficult Sakura or the souls
games I think it depends where you're
coming from like I think they're both
difficult challenges I think the thing
that stands out about souls is the
difficulty is in almost being ambushed
and like it feels like jump scares in a
movie yeah a lot of ways like that's
what makes it really tricky you have to
be very careful and like methodical in
how you move through whereas difficulty
insecure or feels more mechanical if it
was more demanding on you as a player
and not exactly the game tricking you
into being killed like
having an enemy leap on you or like an
enemy that you never faced before
suddenly do a one-hit kill this is like
the enemies are there you can see them
and the challenge is in one working up
the courage to go and fight them to
actually keeping up with them and
showing that you've got the skills to
parry right and the strategy to back off
and jump back in when you need to I
think they're two very different types
of challenge and experience even though
they look quite similar I think
regardless of who you are and your
experience level Secura is going to be
challenging but I think you know the
same can be said of Dark Souls and
blood-borne - similar thought from
Christian howís am i safe going into
cetera as a newcomer - from software
games yeah I mean this is a perfect
point pick up the game and it's it's
quite different from I always think
that's an advantage because the whole
muscle memory yeah because of the muscle
memory thing you're in a better position
like you still need to go in knowing
that it's gonna it's gonna be a tricky
one like it's gonna test you and it's
gonna test how you know willing you are
to get through it but one of the things
that I really like about is like the
stealth aspect of it means that it's not
completely overwhelming like every part
of Dark Souls and blood-borne can be
difficult like every enemy is a threat
whereas because if you use self
effectively not all enemies are
definitely gonna kill you like you can
backstab your way and kind of like we
said thin out the crowd and even the
odds and feel good about doing that and
then take on a really challenging part
of it so it's almost like there's a
stealth game in there that everyone can
enjoy but inevitably and eventually
you'll have to play the from software
part of it which is very very difficult
Valarie REM brings up the point of how
many hours is it to beat the game I know
these games famously have a lot to do
but how many hours you think you could
sink into Sakura and B it varies wildly
I know that Eric in the u.s. finished it
in about 25 but he brute-force a lot of
it and and got a very specific ending
that caters to brute forcing it and but
like I'm I got to like 60 hours before
reaching kind of the end game and a lot
of that involved like the trial and
error aspect of it by also I'm one of
those people that goes back to area just
to speak to NPCs over again and explore
there's a lot of nooks and crannies in
this game I wouldn't describe it as a
Metroidvania game but like Oh
once you get a grappling hook you
realize I need to go back and look at
this thing and there's there's reasons
to backtrack and and see if anything's
changed because sometimes you'll go
there and be like oh this enemy wasn't
here before and if I kill him I can get
one of these upgrade beads and so I
spend a lot of time going back and forth
I think if you just want to complete it
I think the average playthrough will be
around 40 hours but if you're like a
completionist or you want to soak up the
scenery and and really figure things out
I think between 60 and 80
before we let everyone watching this
actually go play the game you have any
final thoughts and Sakura I really
really adore it and it has been a
difficult game to play and especially
one for review because deadlines are not
a good thing not a good stress on top of
all the difficulty of us fight yeah
exactly but like I wouldn't trade it for
the world I absolutely adore it and I'm
already obsessed with it I'm like I said
I'm looking forward to people I've Artie
and Dave and and like various other dogs
the Dark Souls community rallying around
it to figure it out because there's a
lot to figure out there and yeah just
play it it's it's fantastic but if you
want to read the full review that's on
GameSpot calm right now and if you're
struggling in Sakura we have about
Trillian guides you already apps to make
sure you head to GameSpot to actually
you know learn a thing or two hopefully
because I'd know for a fact I wouldn't
been able to beat the blazing Bull if it
wasn't for those guides and if you have
any other questions about Sakura you can
find us on twitter at a regular Dave or
I'm at two more H thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]